hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsensors.com and this is madani
marquette update for tuesday
so first in asia it was a mixed day we
saw the nikkei opening one percent
higher
at 26 200 before revenue all these gains
within the first hours
in the same time s p futures reached the
36 30 mark
getting a fresh boost when investors
were told tesla
would join the 500 listed index soon
which is a very good news for markets
and tesla is set to open 12 higher in
pre-market
at 456 which is close to its all-time
high
at 502 so this might be to me the last
resistance to blow
before we get to our target of 650 but
it seems like equities are having a
break
and some consolidation is taking place
as we saw global indices
fading from the overnight highs around
one percent higher than the open in asia
although the momentum remains still
clearly bullish with some more good
vaccine news
this time moderna who is well placed in
the race for the vaccine since the
beginning
and who has published very promising
results with almost
95 percent of effectiveness on the large
late stage clinical trial
on the volatility side which is what i'm
trading every day at work i'm an option
trader for five years
and we saw some buyers of volatility so
they basically buy call and put options
pushing the vin nike which is the
equivalent of the vix for japan
turning higher at around 22 despite
still quite low realized volatility
which is around 15.
for those who don't know what is the vix
it is an index representing the
volatility of the s p 500
the vix is now trading at 24 which is
consistent with the daily move of 1.5
so it means that investors who are
buying protection are losing money if
the s
p moves less than 1.5 percent
in in one day which is a lot anyways a
vix above 20
means there is tension in the market so
we can expect more big moves to come
watch out guys this market is very
dangerous and you need to be cautious in
every action you take seriously
on the technical side we still hold
above our major support levels
which are 3 500 for s p 3 400 for euro
stocks and 25
500 on nikkei our targets for the coming
month
are intact we are still bullish 37.50 on
snp
which is four percent higher eight
hundred for euro stocks
ten percent higher and twenty seven
thousand on the nikkei which is four
percent higher
so to me it's the euro stocks where i
see the most room on the upside
because its recovery since march loss
has been
the weakest for now once again i will do
some more video very soon to show you
guys
how i came up with these technical
levels and we will monitor
how the market is reacting to the news
this week so watch out you restricted
sales figures
released tonight that would be what
closely by investors
that's it for me for today thanks for
listening and please don't forget to hit
the like button if you enjoyed this
market update
so i would do more bye guys